if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
or BPH your prostate gland is enlarged
the prostate is a walnut-sized gland in
men
just beneath your bladder your prostate
gland surrounds your urethra the tube
through which urine and semen exit your
body
your seminal vesicles and prostate make
fluid that combines with sperm cells to
create semen
during normal urination urine flows from
your bladder through the part of your
urethra inside your prostate then
through the rest of your urethra to
leave your body
for unknown reasons your prostate gland
May enlarge as you get older
if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
your prostate May grow large enough to
compress the part of your urethra that
runs through it
as a result your enlarged prostate may
slow the flow of urine out of your body
when you urinate
left untreated your prostate can get
larger and reduce urine flow even more
this may keep you from fully emptying
your bladder
see your doctor right away if you are
unable to urinate
your risk for benign prostatic
hyperplasia is higher if you are age 40
or older have a family history of BPH
have other health problems such as
obesity diseases of the heart and blood
vessels or type 2 diabetes don't
exercise or have erectile dysfunction
the symptoms of benign prostatic
hyperplasia include frequent urination
or urge to urinate especially at night
a weak or interrupted urine stream and
straining to urinate
over time untreated benign prostatic
hyperplasia may cause the following
complications inability to urinate
damage to your bladder and kidneys
urinary tract infections bladder stones
and blood in your urine
if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
with mild or no symptoms your doctor May
recommend watchful waiting which
includes getting your prostate checked
every year to make sure your symptoms or
health are not getting worse
if you have moderate symptoms that
bother you your doctor May recommend
medications such as alpha blockers or
those that treat erectile dysfunction
called pde5 inhibitors
both of these medications relax muscle
tissue in your bladder urethra and
prostate this can help improve your
urine flow
five Alpha reductase Inhibitors may also
be prescribed this medication helps to
improve urine flow over several months
by reducing the size of your prostate
you may receive a combination of these
drugs
if medication isn't relieving your
symptoms your doctor May recommend a
surgical procedure called transurethral
resection of the prostate or terp
during this procedure your surgeon will
insert an instrument called a
receptoscope through your urethra to
reach your prostate
then a wire loop at the end of the
receptoscope will be used to shave off
tissue
which will widen your urethra
other minimally invasive variations on
this type of procedure use lasers
microwaves radio waves or electrical
energy from tools inserted through the
receptoscope to remove some or all of
your prostate gland
if your prostate is very large your
doctor May recommend an open
prostatectomy procedure
in open prostatectomy your surgeon will
make an incision in your lower abdomen
after exposing your prostate your
surgeon will make an incision in its
outer capsule
next the tissue inside your prostate
will be removed and the capsule incision
will be closed with sutures
finally your skin incision will be
closed with sutures or Staples
you can't prevent benign prostatic
hyperplasia but the following lifestyle
changes can make your symptoms less
severe avoid medication that can make it
harder for you to urinate such as
antihistamines and decongestants
stop drinking fluids for a few hours
before bedtime
avoid drinking alcohol or fluids that
contain caffeine
try to empty your bladder by double
voiding to double void urinate
wait a moment and then try to urinate
again
to find out more about benign prostatic
hyperplasia talk to your Healthcare
practitioner